this is so cute by the way I know that
you love in sync so I'm not surprised by
this but you guys obviously planned this
well you know what I just pop this on
today I go Lauren um is my sister I was
like what do you think about me wearing
my NSYNC sweater tonight she's like I
think that's great statement and then he
saw me in it and he needed to go put
this on I mean she's not gonna wear an
ugly sweater and I'm not going I said it
was fine that's weird but I was telling
her I really wish I had a bachelor boys
other sweater because I would represent
it you guys are wedding planning you
have so many things you have your dress
is that right you have a date picked out
we feel so boring that Sevilla we've
already told you guys this stuff we've
done nothing in the past two months what
do you have left to do well we have
really like to send out the where they
called the say the day goodbye like
January because we need everybody to
save that date I would be disappointed a
pretty much anyone on my list at now
yeah we have a lot of people coming from
LA up front like you know Tanner and
Jane or Kansas City right now and then a
lot of our bachelor friends and family
are over here in Los Angeles and then
her film is in Virginia and New Jersey
so a lot of people are commuting to this
wedding so we just want to get the save
the dates as early as fossils so be like
listen save this date don't mess up
what's been the most challenging process
of wedding planning for you guys
honestly it was just picking the venue
we're just so stressed because we were
looking at year in advance and pretty
much every Saturday in the locale that
we wanted was already sold out for next
year so that was the most stressful part
I don't foresee anything being worse but
who the hell knows
it was just stressful because we were
talking a lot of the people I worked at
these venues and they're like yeah some
of these girls are just engaged to our
works you do not even engaged yet and
they're just planning their wedding day
okay bachelor nation is on that guest
list are in the wedding party well we're
not gonna talk about the wedding party
yet but there will be bachelor alum in
wedding party as long as they accept our
invitation but basically it's Carli Evan
Nick jadianna Becca really a Dean Ben
then and I'm sorry to whoever is the
obvious Kaitlyn Bristowe whoever is
obviously invited that was yeah there be
a lot of people in bachelor nation there
which is great
how is Kaitlyn doing by the way I mean I
can't say yeah but it's really sad
that's one of those couples that you
just when anybody would ask like oh is
it real and like yeah like looking for
Kaitlyn and Shawn and Carlene evident
and J they were one of those couples
that's just like you really root for but
I hope they're both happy and I hope
they're both doing what's best for them
and each other all that good stuff so
you guys are here with Nick tonight and
you're good friends with Ben you also
mentioned them how do we find them love
oh well we definitely want to find both
of them love but it shouldn't be that
hard
surely you're both such good-looking
eligible bachelors it boggles my mind
there sis ago but you know what let's
just make them so : is this New Year's
bachelor how about next year we just put
bring them both back and it's like a -
bachelor that's pretty good Nick and Ben
both back for the same season and
there's no voting they both go through
the entire season Nick and Ben together
for the first time in the history of the
franchise that's really cool just
buddies have you pitched that can you
pitch that I literally just thought of
that so I mean I see Chris Harrison over
there so if they remained a pitcher -
it's that guy really fast just want to
ask you holiday traditions are you guys
having to compromise at all and what are
you guys doing it's a common rise of
course because you have to pickle you
know we did things give me in my house
we're gonna do Christmas in his house
and now we're talking about like New
Year's what we can do for New Year's cuz
that's a new
you got that I got Christmas no New
Year's it's like okay well flip the coin
what he has new year's traditions that I
don't I hate New Year's and he's always
loved it I love staying New Britain
staying in ordering Chinese
that's why it's good for him because he
decides to stay in watching New Year's
rockin Eve it's just like this is my jam
it's gonna be your jam too and last
question you opened up about you we're
gonna freeze your age yeah how soon are
you guys talking about having kids is
that a conversation that's happening
we're he's thinking like six months
after we get married so if you like my
32nd birthday yeah 2020 that would that
I would try yeah
[Music]